if you
if you listen to these contributions,
you will receive 1 type
almost dizzy from that turning
find it really fascinated madam
oh well really
I see here by the way 1 pair of VVDs are those
uh,
those eyes are quite satisfied
I even saw them laugh once in a while
you have been running seriously
where is on the VVD glue tape
when it comes to the deductible
the mouth saw 1 BAK impatience next
my question is
I am going to try it one more time
because really where no one has received 1 answer
and only mrs bicker is 1 bit finished by uh
by Mrs.
Aagema in one very nasty way
but I would appreciate it if you at least
1 question would like to answer
that is the very first question I have asked
you go 1 proposal from the sp
support for both the abolition of the deductible
as oral care in the boss package
i think millions of people
who have been waiting for that for years
straight up on that simple question
and also do not deposit with 1 minister
it's really too easy this